[Music]
this is you guys overestimated the
height that's okay one of these is this
weird let's stand up comedy after this
over here on your left hi hi over here
where are you on your left on my left
how far wondering thing do you feel like
best new artist no I don't I honestly I
mean I know that sounds really cliche
like I didn't expect this but I like I'm
such a huge fan of all the other artists
that were nominated so I like I would
have been just as happy if they if they
won I mean there are just so many people
making great stuff right now so I don't
feel like the best but and this doesn't
mean I'm the best either but it's a
really crazy accomplishment either way
I'm also interested in the new part of
that as well
Onew well I mean it just doesn't none of
this feels real to be honest yeah it's
just I don't even know what to say it
doesn't feel real it doesn't feel like
I'm here it's probably won't process
this for another like seven years or
something thanks from Mexico haha are
you working in something new can you
tell us so what are you doing now yeah
so I'm working on a new album right now
I'm not sure when it'll be out it's
almost done I've been writing it for a
while and I'm really excited about it
I'm proud of it and it's it's really
honest and all that good stuff I'm not
right now I don't know I don't know
about that maybe we'll see thank you
could you address
you mentioned everyone deserves the same
shot yes could you kind of elaborate on
that what um yeah well of course I meant
I mean in regards to the music industry
I think there's some really really
awesome artists that have started
amazing trends and that are doing such
incredible things but don't get the same
shot or the same acknowledgement because
they're not particularly mainstream or
they're not on the charts and I think
it's important that everyone deserves
the same shot and everyone should get
one of these and be acknowledged for the
amazing work that they do and not
everyone does so and of course just in
regards to the world I think you know
it's very unequal and uneven and
everyone deserves the same shot
life and success so yeah Alessia hi hi
um
good to see you as well a lot of great
pop music had came out of the Greater
Toronto Area wire to you releasing an
album and coming out but what do you
think this means now for other aspiring
artists in the GTA that you've taken on
this Grammy well I mean I hope people
can see it as some doors opening for
them and I mean I know when I was coming
out of Brampton I just didn't think I
would ever make it here you know you
just think oh it's never gonna happen so
I hope that people can see that no
matter where you're from it's it's
totally possible has the successive stay
and this album influenced your new music
that you're working on or now um I mean
I don't think particularly stay like
sonically cuz I wouldn't have been that
bold on my own stuff like you know to do
that whole dance thing but it's
definitely inspired me to let go and
just try new things for sure
Congrats Thanks
um yeah I mean I've always loved Alanis
Morrisette Corsa Nelly Furtado who
actually used to be managed by my
manager which is cool fun little fact um
yeah those are the females for sure and
then of course a Drake and all those
cool Toronto guys thank you hey yeah so
yeah the white rose I think for me it
just means speaking up for not only
women in the entertainment industry of
course that you know are treated
unequally but just women who don't have
a voice that in the aren't as lucky to
have a platform like I am and just you
know stating the obvious stating the
fact that things are uneven and unequal
and they they need to be talked about
and need to be changed yeah thanks
Alysia congratulations we all know is
right to dream right yes music and
action podcasts congratulate you when
you were a kid doing fake acceptance
features for the Grammys right yeah did
you imagine it what you just happened no
because I I would just like thank like
non-existent people for non-existent
music and stuff so I just didn't I
didn't think I would I mean I obviously
wasn't as nervous as I was like in my
shower I was definitely more calm and
collected as a kid in my shower
but um yeah I just didn't expect any of
this I know that sounds really cheesy
and dumb to say but it's true like you
don't you don't really think it'll
happen to you as much as you hope it
would so yeah thank you thanks
congratulations thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]